apparently schools
are not doing a good job of teaching
money schools just don't teach money
they just don't here's the deal
here's a report from cnbc report cards
are in i know school just started but
there's already report cards out
regarding
what schools are doing to teach money
and here's the story 66 percent of
states
earn a c grade or worse for personal
finance education see greater worse so
here's the story now the story basically
delves into the fact that states could
do a far better job of teaching
financial literacy in their schools this
report suggests 31 states how many
states are there in the country marcelo
there is about 50 there's about
like a washington dc in there we got
puerto rico it's a territory so it's 50
at least maybe a little bit more all
right let's call it 50. let's let's call
it 50. now 31 of these states
earned a c
or worse
c or worse so that means 60 of the
states can't even
get a a decent grade in teaching
personal finance now this is according
to the nation's report card on financial
literacy i got one big yikes coming your
way marcelo
did you ever take a personal finance
class in school i think i might have
taken one yeah but uh it just it wasn't
it wasn't enough to stick in my brain i
feel like i took i took like seven
spanish classes eight english classes
nine you know
geography well what's crazy about you
taking spanish classes is that you
actually speak spanish yeah
i didn't need the classes you didn't
need the classes zero mom taught me the
most important spanish class i did not
take a personal finance class in school
which we'll touch on in a second anyway
here's some here's what this report
covers the report relied on factors
like
graduation requirements standards and
curriculum to created stories now how
many
of these states actually did a decent
grade an a or b right c is what i would
call average right so
60 of states 31 31 states
are basically average they're not doing
anything above the average to teach you
about money all right 12 states were
given a b okay not bad
five states
actually received an a
now i'm going to say these states does
anybody have any guesses of what you
think give me one of these fi of five
states that you actually believe
got an a give me one state in the
comment section i'd love to see what you
guys going on right there i would have
guessed new york new york right the
stock market's there wall street you
would expect they'd teach you know
they'd get an a financial literature
paul do you have any guesses of what
state you think would be of one of these
five states that got an a
[Music]
i'm gonna go la
la california
i want to say that we were positive he
didn't take a financial literacy class
we're also positive he didn't pass his
geography any class high school yeah
really yeah gonna go l.a
uh chicago is also a big state huge
state jorge you wanna guess what state
you think got an a in personal finance
classes
texas he said texas okay it's a big
statement it's a big state it's a big
state all right i see what people are
saying new york dc connecticut florida
new york
texas florida maine vermont new york
virginia hawaii i see a lot of things
right there
none of you
none of you
guessed the correct state we got
new york nevada texas florida
massachusetts
not one of you guys go right guess the
correct state you ready for this i'm
almost going to do like a proverbial
drum roll right here
just five states received an a grade
here are the states
missouri
nebraska
north carolina utah and virginia
utah nobody guessed these states now why
are these states giving a's
getting is well here these states are
mandating
financial education from kindergarten
through 12th grade and require a
standalone personal finance course for
high school graduation now that's the
way to do it i'm not in favor of
mandates if you've ever watched a pbd
podcast we're not like you have to do
this everybody likes choices everybody
likes options nobody's likes you have to
do this i mean you kind of have to go to
school
right stay you know mandates of school
and you're gonna have to deal with money
some day or another yes you know and if
you want to avoid that
you're going to be uh
not so good i find it interesting sonic
i find one thing quite interesting about
this allow me to jump in here with my
soprano voice yes um the one thing i do
think is interesting is i could tell you
who hades is
you know what i mean hades from greek
mythology yeah haiti some girls
i can tell you about him i can tell you
about a story about him yeah
but i have no idea how to do my taxes
i have zero idea how to do my taxes
i can't do them i don't even know why
when when my when the accountant tells
me how much money i get back i couldn't
tell you why i'm gonna get that money
back yeah and i think that's something
these kids maybe should learn of course
it is maybe we replaced that lesson take
out hades put in taxes that day that you
spend on hades let's talk taxes what do
you think about that i think we should
touch on that well here let's let's just
finish the story and then we'll have a
little dialogue here
um so those are the states that got an a
meanwhile there's four
states or four areas
that got an f these guys are failing
badly any guesses on those before we
proceed any guesses on which states are
getting an f in personal finance do you
want to make a guess
i mean
i am just i want to like get ahead of it
i think people are going to say florida
i think we were going to say that and i
want to i want to defend us i think we
don't i don't think i don't think we got
enough
paul
state name a state that got an f so
to be honest because i was doing
multiple things when you asked the first
time yes i thought that was the question
so my answer for california i thought
california would get now okay well
sticking with is la yeah what state
jorge any guesses
um
philadelphia philadelphia also not a
state state we're crushing geography
no more
okay we got new michigan we got maryland
we got new jersey of course we got a
couple floridas california new york
illinois california mississippi oregon
illinois thank you guys in the comment
section for being this actively engaged
people are moving these people are
moving they're grooving they're making
guesses and nobody has been right so far
including the two peanut gallery over
here that think that cities are now
states and then i got hades over there
here are the four spots that are getting
f's
in school when it comes to personal
finance alaska they're probably teaching
fishing and whale watching
south dakota yeah all right south dakota
which is like
i don't know i don't know anything
probably one of the worst dakotas okay
um
washington d.c not a state capital you
you know are you shocked that in the
capital united states that personal
finance and money management of all the
debt that we got going on this country
and the non-budgeting they are not
teaching personal finance when there's
smoke there's fire everywhere in our
politicians
disaster horrible at budgeting that's
the um
territory to get an f and then the last
but not least puerto rico all my
barricos out there they can dance their
ass off but apparently are not learning
about personal finances not in school
it's a problem so and they got f's for
failing to guarantee any financial
literacy instructions at all that's like
my soprano at all at all ridiculous so
look let's get back to your point
teaching about hades we all take the
most useless classes in school maybe not
useless but classes that i would venture
to say 99 of us never use again we all
use algebra biology chemistry
trigonometry
greek mythology i took wood shop you
think i'm picking up a
a saw that ain't happening the cool
thing about wood shop is there's always
one kid that that starts to communicate
with the wood you know what i mean
there's like a kid that like this is his
language yeah you know what i mean he's
like i had no idea me and wood are meant
to be so other than that kid though
you're right it's not gonna help no so
this is this is actually the impetus for
me starting my entire show was i never
learned about money in school i was a
jack of all trades all throughout my 20s
i was a stand-up comedian i was a club
promoter i was a nightlife guy i dabbled
in real estate i was a teacher i
couldn't find my way out of a paper bag
when it came to money but then i got a
job as a cold caller and i my first year
i made five thousand dollars in one year
i was broke as a joke i was lucky to
live on a friend with a decent couch for
me boom my second year making 100 g's
boom financial recession hits 2008 i'm
28 years old freaking disaster i don't
know what to do but i knew to save that
money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay
[Music]
is
broken